so perhaps birthday first o'clock meet  in meeting a potential new client for  brand video potentially but Amma going  my earth my director a more special silk  but how do we get the knee that more  come through did we pick up the phone no  no we did eventually they call does me  they call this that's what it's about so  bound we see how guys first client  meeting Dan really enjoyed it it was  interesting to yeah we speaking to a  recruitment business as my client but  it's really interesting to hear sort of  the problems that face and in terms of  the growth plans that they have and not  actually having any internal process up  until this point so yeah really enjoyed  it  I'm ah what do you think mate first me  and good me yeah good man